good morning Merry Christmas uh I'm
Adrien dicks uh BC minister of Health to
my right is Dr Bonnie Henry BC's
provincial Health officer honored to
provide uh to you a briefing on
respiratory illness season today uh
we're both honored to be on the
territory of laang speaking people the
sis and the aanal First Nations and with
that it's my honor to introduce Dr
Bonnie
Henry thank you very much and good
morning um today we're going to share
some information about the respiratory
illness season what we're seeing across
British Columbia and the ongoing
immunization campaign and it's
particularly important as we're heading
into that holiday season where we all
want to spend time with friends and
family and love ones and particularly
with the indoor Gatherings that we tend
to have this time of year so the good
news is that covid-19 activity continues
to to to decrease and stay relatively
low since the peak that we had in early
October this year while influenza A on
the other hand and it's mostly the H1N1
strain and RSV activity are starting to
increase now and this is important this
is something why we need to pay
attention to what's going on right now
we're also seeing that more people are
are seeking health care providers for
respiratory symptoms in the last several
weeks so that's going up both in adults
and in children the bccdc weekly data
updates which you can see on their
website every Thursday show make it
clear that we are well into respiratory
season and it's looking much more like
the typical Seasons we used to have
prior to the pandemic with Peaks
particularly of influenza and RSV but
influen wza we tend to see Peaks after
the holiday period in early uh late
December early January so now is the
time where we can take preventive
measures to try and stop that Peak we're
also seeing a variety of other viruses
causing illnesses over the holiday
season and again that's similar to what
we used to see before covid came on the
scene so as I mentioned the covid-19
test positivity cases hospitalizations
and deaths have de in since early
October when our vaccination program
began and are remaining low but steady
in BC and I know many people I talked to
have had uh friends and family who have
had covid in the last few months the
trends and indicators of of covid-19
activity vary across the provinces and
territories in the country and what we
see is that it is increased slightly in
some other areas uh of the country in
recent weeks and this reminds us that we
are in a transition year still it's not
clear yet what pattern the SARS coov V2
virus is going to take um we're still
trying to understand the seasonality of
it or if there is going to be a pattern
and what pattern that will be in the
long term in the past few years since it
came on the scene we have seen an
increase again in the spring so we'll be
continuing to monitor that and again it
reminds us that we can take prevention
measures now that will help us into the
spring as well and primarily that means
getting that up dated covid vaccine so
while influenza A Levels continue to
increase at various monitored sites so
both the emergency department visits
visits to to primary care physicians and
our Wastewater surveillance the test
positivity starting to increase we're
well within what we call the normal
respiratory illness season for influenza
right now as I mentioned the majority of
of what we're seeing right now when we
do the whole genome sequencing is the h
One n one strain and in some ways that's
a really uh good thing it tends to cause
less severe illness than the H3N2 strain
that we also see
circulating and which is especially
problematic particularly for older
people but the other thing that we do
know is that H1N1 can cause more Sub
earliness in younger people so we need
to be aware of that and we need to make
sure that we protect young people as
well and anybody over 6 months of age is
eligible for the um influenza vaccine
and why we'll have vaccine Effectiveness
data later in the season we have taken a
look at the bccdc lab they've taken a
look at the genetic information we have
from what those influenza viruses that
are circulating so far in BC and we can
see that they match very closely to
these strains of influenza virus used to
make this year's annual vaccine so what
that means is that the influ in
influenza vaccines that we have
available now for everybody should be
very effective in helping protect you
and your loved ones from getting
seriously sick if you get influenza in
the next little while so that reminds us
it's not too late to get that extra
protection by getting vaccinated
particularly before spending time with
family especially young children older
family members people in Long-Term Care
Homes who are more likely to have more
severe illness or
complications terms of the other major
virus that we see around this year this
uh time of year RSV or respiratory
sensial virus data from BC Children's
Hospital from bccdc show that RSV is is
increasingly causing illness especially
in children and we've saw that in the
last two years in particular we fle um
the Wastewater surveillance that we're
doing shows that it's particularly
increased in the Fraser Health Region
and the Vancouver Coastal Health Region
the test positivity is high amongst
children and we know that RSV has a
particular impact each year amongst very
young children particularly the first
times that you're exposed to it and we
saw in the last two years where we
didn't have RSV for a year or two that
it did have a an increased impact and
relatively earlier in the season last
year so we're seeing a more normal
pattern this year again but we know that
it can cause very severe illness in
young children and so
um both rsva and B so we're learning a
lot more about RSV from some of the uh
work that we're doing particularly
around uh Wastewater surveillance and
the whole genome sequencing program and
we're understanding that there's more
than one type of RSV and and looking at
those
patterns we also know there are many
other cold viruses that are making
people sick right now and they're have
names like adenovirus and entov viruses
and Par influenza
so we know and I know people have been
telling me and I've seen it in my
friends and family too that there's lots
of people out there with the snipples
and coughs and colds and this is
reflected in overall adult emergency
department visit for respiratory
symptoms and visits to Primary Care
Providers have increased in the last few
weeks and we see the same thing in
pediatric emergency department visits so
we know we are in that part part of the
season right now where things are are in
increasing and we know we're also coming
to that point of time where we want to
get together with others so while
specifically for covid-19 the number of
hospitalizations per week has decreased
from the peak of about 330 that we had
in the first week of October and our
most recent data shows that there's 182
people in hospital with a positive covid
test and 17 of those are in critical
care but the remains High rates of
emergency department visits and some
hospital visits for other respiratory
illnesses I know there's been a concern
raised uh we've heard it in reported in
the media and other places about
children particularly in China being ill
and the the concern about micoplasma
pneumonia which is a type of pneumonia
um that can that we see sporadically and
we have been monitoring that both at the
public health laboratory here at bccdc
and in collaboration with BC Children's
Hospital and we have seen some sporadic
cases of micoplasma but not an increase
um by in adults or children above what
we would normally see in a pre-pandemic
year in
VC it is important that in the midst of
respiratory Seasons a variety of
different ruses or bacteria can cause
these infections and if symptoms are
severe so particularly if you have
difficulty breathing or you're not
improving after a few days to a week it
is important to continue to seek medical
I
attention but going back to it there are
things that we can do that will help the
single most important thing we can do to
prevent getting sick in this time of
year is to strengthen our immune system
by getting the updated covid vaccines
and our influenza vaccine and most
people this year are able to get those
at the same time we know that this
process began in October with our
priority population so older people
residents of Long-Term Care Homes
indigenous people pregnant people
healthcare
workers to date uh by the end of of
yesterday we had administered over 1.4
million doses of influenza vaccines and
more than 1.2 million doses of the covid
vaccines this season so we know that
these are well matched as I mentioned to
what we're seeing circulate and for
those who have not yet booked your
appointment get that gift now if you get
those vaccines this week they're widely
available across the province in over
800 pharmacies and you can get those
vaccines now you'll be protected as you
go into the the main part of the holiday
season you do this for yourself for your
friends your family your teammates and
for our
community we know from what we've seen
in the past years that the holidays can
be a time where illness spreads when we
get together with family friends loved
ones and primarily
indoors and we need need to keep our
guard up and take important steps like
getting those vaccines
now as well we want to make sure that
when we do get together we get together
safely we know there are important
messages that remind people again the
importance of those healthy habits
cleaning our hands regularly cover your
cough or sneeze wearing a mask if you're
going to be in indoor spaces with others
and you have mild symptoms or still
recovering or if you're somebody who is
at high risk yourself you can consider
wearing a well-fitted mask if if you
need to be in indoor crowded spaces but
really importantly this includes staying
home if you have symptoms of a cough or
runny nose fatigue and especially a
fever a fever is generally an indication
that you have something that may be
transmissible to others and so if you're
the one hosting or part of gatherings
this holiday season make it okay for
people who aren't feeling well not to
come in person we have all learned over
these last few ways or through years
ways to make it easy and meaningful for
people to participate remotely and still
be part of the Gathering whether it's
using visual virtual visits or
postponing a visit to somebody in
long-term care until you are well these
are ways we show our love and and
protect those who are at most risk of
severe illness or complications if they
get
sick as I said there's plenty of supply
of vaccine provincewide and you can get
an appointment in your area this week
um and like the more than a million
people who've already done that we can
all do our part and it is not too late
to make a big difference in trying to to
um post prevent the spread of influenza
over the next few
weeks I want to especially urge those
who are over age of 80 or people who are
clinically extremely vulnerable to book
your shot today we know that over half
of people over age 65 have gotten both
their vaccines but but there's still a
risk out there for
many so the other thing I I want to note
is that last week Health Canada approved
the updated novavax vaccine so this is a
more traditional protein subunit vaccine
uh also designed to protect against the
the circulating strain so it's based on
the xbb uh SARS CO2 strain as well and
it will be available starting this week
in BC for people who prefer not to have
the MRNA vaccines or have had issues
with them in the past and it's available
for people 12 years of age and So for
anybody who does still need to book an
appointment or wants to find about out
about the novavax vaccine I encourage
you to call 1833 838 2323 for assistance
if you need it or you can go to the get
registered
online I do want to make a just a few
comments about Aven influenza you may be
aware that we continue to see an
increase in in high pathogenic Aven
influenza
activity in British Columbia and that's
affecting more than 50 flocks around
primarily the Lower Mainland but also
the interior and some here on Vancouver
Island have been infected with this
strain of of bird flu or Aven influenza
called
h5n1 there's always a concern that a
person could become infected with human
influenza and Aven influenza at the same
time and that could provide an
opportunity for this virus to mutate to
infect humans more easily and increase
the risk of a
pandemic to reduce that potential
getting the seasonal influenza vaccine
is especially important for people who
are working in the poultry industry and
we've been having a partnership with the
Ministry of Agriculture with cfia with
the poultry producers here and and uh
Public Health to make sure that people
working in the industry have access to
vaccine and to the personal protective
equipment they need and while we know
that this virus is spreading GL globally
um through migratory wild fowl so things
like ducks and geese who migrate and it
mostly affects birds like chickens
turkey geese and Ducks it can affect
other wild animals and we've seen that
happen as well including cats and bears
and
mink this is a good opportunity to
remind everyone that if you do come
across sick or dead wild animal or Birds
you shouldn't touch them or bring them
home with you and make sure that pets as
well um keep them away from sick or dead
animals you can report them as well um
if you come across a dead bird you can
report it by calling 18866 431 bird
which is
2473 so generally as we enter this
holiday season and celebrations and
Gatherings be so important for us after
all we've been through in the last few
years is time now it's not too late to
get your updated covid-19 and influenza
vaccines if you haven't done that
already we all need to continue to do
this part for ourselves for our family
our friends and for those who are more
vulnerable in our
communities so the best things we can do
are staying up to dat with our
vaccinations taking those regular
precautions that should be part of our
life now like covering your mouth with
your sleeve or elbow when you cough
wearing a mask when it's needed cleaning
your hands regularly and of course
checking in with yourself and your
children and making sure if you are sick
with something that can pass on to
others that you stay away until you're
feeling better we can all spend time
with the ones we love and ensure we
aren't passing on an unwanted guest at
the same time so thank you very much I
hope everybody enjoys a happy and safe
and healthy holiday season I'll turn it
over to minister
dick uh thank you very much and uh thank
you very much Dr Henry and I really want
to acknowledge um the exceptional work
of uh everybody in public health uh
everybody who works in Community
Pharmacy and hospitals the community
around communities around British
Colombian long-term care for all of
their work this year and throughout the
pandemic we forget the extraordinary
sacrifice sometimes as we try and focus
and sometimes we try and move on to
other things that people have made and
it continues to be shown in some
exceptional results that we've had in
British Columbia uh I want to just touch
on quickly on three subjects the first
uh vaccination the second uh
hospitalization uh and the third um
surgeries in BC as part of uh uh this
update uh since the start of the
pandemic people have BC and they've been
the key element in all this have have uh
adopted vaccination more than virtually
any other jurisdiction in North America
that is certainly true this year as Dr
Henry has said as of uh December 10th uh
uh last night at midnight BC had
administered 1,4
43,7 52 doses of flu vaccines and
1,289 1849 doses of covid-19 vaccines
and these uh results compare uh with uh
what we did last year when obviously
there was uh more intensity around these
questions last year both for influenza
and for covid-19 and it's in fact one of
the reasons I think that we've seen some
better results particularly with pi to
covid-19 uh so far last year we had a
record-breaking uh influenza vaccine
season as you'll know and at this time
last year week nine of the campaign we
were at 1.5 1 million um and last year
at this time in the covid-19 fall
campaign we were at 1.18 million so
we're slightly ahead of where we were on
covid-19 slightly behind where we were
on influenza last year but in terms of
national comparison uh what has happened
here in British Columbia and I think it
really reflects on um the commitment of
people to one another here the
commitment to get vaccinated and this
vaccination system that is put in place
that is in some ways a legacy of um the
work done in covid-19 the immunization
system and BC and the work by both
public health and Community Pharmacy
just as an example and these are
National statistics from last week from
December 3rd the level of vaccination
Bri Bri Columbia against uh again with
the with the new covid-19 vaccines is
twice as high as it is in Ontario Twice
as high well above any other
jurisdiction in the country and this
reflects well I think on what we're
doing in BC but of course this is not
the Canada games and we want everybody
to do well we want everybody to be first
and of course every day people come from
other jurisdictions in the country to
British Columbia and this is an argument
to get vaccinated in British Columbia to
take this advantage of this period when
there are in some health authorities uh
90% availability of appointments um to
get vaccinated here in British Columbia
it will protect you your loved ones if
you have a multigenerational family it's
important to get vaccinated if you have
grandparents it's important to get
vaccinated if your brother has Type 1
diabetes it's important to get
vaccinated it's important to get
vaccinated and that is true in other
jurisdictions as well if you're coming
home to British Columbia get vaccinated
if you're not coming home to British
Columbia over Christmas get vaccinated
this is an important time to take
advantage of the availability in every
province in Canada and in communities in
every part of British Columbia to get
vaccinated and I I really encourage
people to take that opportunity we are
doing better than everywhere else but
but that that doesn't help you if you
haven't been vaccinated it's important
to take this opportunity to do so and I
strongly encourage everyone to do so one
of the reasons why it's a value I think
um to um to get vaccinated is the impact
it can have and the support it can have
for our hospitals as we go through as
we've seen um a record uh uh period of
demand for health care services in BC
for covid-19 as Dr Henry has said
hospitalizations um the number of
hospitalizations is down uh decrease
from a peak of 334 from October 1st to 7
to 116 from November 26th to December
2nd it's this is encouraging to see
you'll remember for example in the week
of January 24th to 30th we had an
average hospitalization of covid-19 uh
of 2022 I should say during the Omicron
variant of concern we had an average
hospitalization rate of
973 this is better and uh and uh but in
addition uh uh we also are dealing with
other respiratory illnesses and dealing
as I noted with significant demand for
health care that significant demand for
healthare is reflected in our acute care
census uh you'll recall as we prepared
for Respiratory illness season this year
we increased our base bed capacity in BC
in other words the base hospital bed
capacity of the province from 9,200 to
9,929 and what we're seeing right now is
that those beds are of course fully
allocated we also have a significant
number of surge beds in addition to that
as well another uh significant number of
Beds which allows us to um to respond to
increased demand as of December 7th the
number of hospitalized impatients in BC
was
10,12 it's the peak this winter so far
or this fall I should say is
10,128 and um for we've put in place
access and flow teams for all hospitals
7 days a week we prioritized Healthcare
Services we've increased the number of
acute care beds and the work and the
teamwork of bchs and our hospitals is
excellent but we are seeing significant
uh demand for Hospital services and it
justifies the decisions made to increase
and to regularize hospital beds in our
system we're also adding things like
hospital at home beds and so I think I
think uh throughout the system we are
better prepared than we have been at any
time uh to deal with these large number
of of patients but the fact of the
matter is that we're facing in a
continued period in the course of a week
of 10,000 patients in our public
Healthcare System as a result uh as a
result We are continuing to prepare as
we have been preparing to since
September for what we would expect to
see a growth in in those numbers in the
first part of January which is our
absolute peak season you'll recall that
last year in January at around January
6th we reached
10,280 impatients in hospital in British
Columbia and we are approximately
170 above where we were last year right
now so if that pattern were to be
maintained we would be seeing record
numbers of people in hospital and that's
why we've taken such significant actions
uh to prepare for that uh finally I just
want to talk about um briefly about the
surgical renewal uh commitment of the
province and just to to note that we
have been performing uh uh the public
Healthcare System our doctors our nurses
our Health Sciences professionals all
the people who keep uh operating rooms
clean and all the people who work on the
administration of our surgical system we
have been performing at the highest
level ever as a health system and as a
province in the week of October 20 202nd
to October 28th performed
7,781 surgeries which is an alltime
record in fact shatters an all-time
record it's not quite uh Bob Beeman but
it's still a very significant increase
in the number of surgeries done and that
means people getting care sooner in our
Province the the overall records is
record was a record October record
November or Record December in the
number of surgeries performed in BC and
this is a real reflection of the work
that has been done since May 2020 to put
surgical renew in effect it's meant more
uh more anesthesiologists more operating
room nurses a health Human Resources
plan around surgery that was significant
and an absolute increase in our capacity
in every part of the province uh to do
surgeries we are we still face
challenges in some communities as you
know and there's sometimes significant
reports when we can when we can't
perform or we don't have full capacity
of 100 or 200 surgeries we're talking
about every week breaking the overall
numbers for surgeries by hundreds here
on Vancouver Island for example and
everywhere else in BC so this is a real
achievement of our public Healthcare
System but of course to do so and to
continue to see this level of work also
increases demand in our hospitals it's
the kind of demand that we we want to
have because we want people to get their
surgeries as soon as possible but it
really is an argument for us to do in
this respiratory illness season to adopt
healthy habits that we've that we've
learned during the covid-19 pandemic to
stay home when you're sick that's
critically important to to uh to uh wash
your hands regularly it's critically
important did I say stay home when
you're sick that's really important and
that means not just going to work but
that means going to family gatherings
and other things where you can
potentially have vulnerable people near
you and finally get vaccinated it's
there are appointments available in
every Community There's an opportunity
to get vaccinated it takes very little
time very little effort and the benefit
not just for you but for your family and
your loved ones and your community those
that you know and you do not know is
profound I am very proud I am very proud
of British Colombia's response to the
covid-19 pandemic and to these profound
public health issues that we faced
unprecedented in our lifetimes at least
in my lifetime and we've got to continue
to do that British Colombians have led
the way not the health system not the
government British Colombians have led
the way and this fall and this winter we
need to continue to do that and take the
opportunity as we enter into this
holiday season into the Christmas season
to uh to get vaccinated thank you very
much and I'll return the podium to Dr
Henry we'll happy to take your
questions a reminder to reporters on the
line to press star one to enter the
queue reporters will be able to ask one
question and one followup um we'll start
in the room uh Richard zman Global News
go ahead Richard Dr Henry we look at the
numbers and terms of vaccination rates
Minister dick said this as well they've
gone down in all the health authorities
uh we look at covid cases they are less
significant they have been in the past
what is the province doing to increase
those immunization rates rather than
just stand up here and say go get a shot
considering we may have a waning all
those who wanted to get it have gone to
get it and we may be at that point where
it's just sort of flatlining well I
think there's a couple of things there
um one is our our get vaccinated system
is sending out reminders to people and
that we know is the effective way to to
trigger that um the other thing that
we're seeing and that I'm hearing from
people is many people have had covid
over the last few months usually if
they're vaccinated a relatively mild
illness so we have suggested that people
wait around 3 months or so because
getting a vaccine right after an
infection doesn't boost your immunity
that much so now we're starting to see
people more people coming in than than
for the flu vaccine so that tells me
that there are some people who have been
waiting either because it wasn't five or
six months since they had their last
covid vaccine or because they had an
infection in between but really
important now as we go into this season
we're starting to see influenza again an
influenza A can cause very severe
illness it's a more normal pattern from
what we were seeing prior to the
pandemic so we expect that that's going
to increase still so never too late and
particularly get it this week and you'll
have the maximum protection as we go
into the main part of the holiday
season go ahead with the followup if you
go and get your vaccine people have
waited for normaly around the holiday
season for three plus years now even
last year events were
cancelled what do you say to someone who
is finally waiting to go to that holiday
party that they have waited three plus
years to and they experience the
sniffles and maybe a sore
throat haven't we asked people to do
enough in essence considering we aren't
seeing that severe of outcomes when it
comes to flu and Co in terms of
hospitalizations yeah and you know this
is the thing that we've learned is what
may be a mild illness for me may not be
a mild illness for somebody who's more
at risk so particularly our elders and
seniors we know that um what can be mild
for us even after vaccination can cause
more severe illness and we see that with
influenza as well so we've learned all
kinds of ways that people can
meaningfully come together and
participate in these events together so
find ways to do that make it okay if uh
the kids aren't feeling well for you to
have a a separate at home party with uh
other family members and postpone it um
postpone it for a time when everybody's
feeling well if you can you know these
are these are moments where we don't
want to ruin it by passing on a virus
even if it's just a cold virus to
somebody who may get really sick with it
so if we have family members who are
going through chemotherapy who are
immune compromised we need to all say
it's okay for us um not to come together
for not feeling
well great next question Rob buffam CTV
hi Dr Henry um just wondering if I
understand the numbers correctly this is
the second year in a row that FL shots
there's been more of those administr
than Co shots
um are we sort of is this the new normal
now and in terms of people feeling as
though Co is maybe not as big of a
concern and are you more worried about
flu than you are Co at this point well
yes and no it's we still don't know yet
about the seasonality of Co so the shot
that you get now I think you
interestingly that our decrease really
correspondent with the peak of
vaccination when we started vaccination
program which tells me that we can have
an effect on on Co but we know that it's
still around and we're seeing in other
provinces um that in particularly in
areas with low immunization rates that
they're starting to see increases again
and in the last two years we've also
seen peaks in the spring so there's
things that we don't yet know about the
SARS K2 virus and whether what pattern
it's going to fall into but I am
thinking that more and more we're like
likely to get be similar to influenza
where we get a an updated vaccine on a
periodic basis whether that me means
yearly or every couple years the virus
is not changing as fast as it was
changing previously and part of that is
because of the level of immunity and the
the there's only certain things that the
virus can do so we're still seeing a lot
of hv1 in the ba 2.86 and you know the
switching of of the virus is not as fast
as it was before so still don't know
about that I've always been concerned
about influenza and you know what I see
is we we usually see people who are at
highest risk get their vaccines first
and then for younger people they may not
think about it but the H1N1 that we're
seeing this year can cause severe
illness in children we know that so
children need their influenza vaccines
too as do older people and yes at this
point in time you know Co seems to be
low steady hasn't gone away way but in
the next few weeks we're going to see
more influenza so I am concerned about
it today but you know as we go into the
uh to the winter season and into the
spring that may change again so what you
do now will protect you for that as well
just just just one thing on the numbers
that you you said Rob uh what you're
seeing is a closing of those numbers now
so early on in the season early on in
the in our in our immunization season
there was a gap that developed I think
it was about 220,000 and then it's been
dropping over the last number of weeks
and it's partly because of Eligibility
like there were very few people
obviously essentially no one had had
influenza in the period immediately
before the shot so they were all
eligible to get it right at that point
there was no one who had got it say in
the summer who were a vaccine taking
population if you will so that number is
closing and I think it's going to end up
pretty close to even between the two so
I don't think what you were suggesting
was happening is actually happening I
think you'll see as we get through the
season say we get to the end of the
vaccination season today January 10th
15th it'll be pretty
close rob you have a followup I do
thanks um just wondering about you know
when you look at these numbers even for
people who are over 80 and clinically
vulnerable who've had access to to a CO
shot since early October presumably
would Tak AC if they wanted to by now
it's last than 50% ob's population I
know that compares favorably to the rest
of the country but are you concerned
that there's still presumably are
otherwise you wouldn't be making this
announcement today but tell me about
that and then I I wanted to rule in as
well just by way of clarity if somebody
if I test for positive for Co tomorrow
morning and I've got a sore throat or
anyone else does what's your advice does
it remain if you don't if you're able to
go about your normal functions go to
work maybe don't go to a Christmas party
with a elderly grandparent but you can
go to work and continue like your advice
has been yeah so uh so in terms of of um
sorry your first question was about am I
concerned about you know we look at age
group and people with underlying uh
immune compromising conditions Etc and
and the rates go up when you split it
like that but yes there are still people
out there who are at risk of having
severe illness from covid from influenza
who have not yet been vaccinated and
that's one of the reasons we're talking
today is to say it's not too late and
particularly if you're going to be
around others if you're in large family
groups if you have kids and and Elders
coming together you know we all need to
do the best we can to protect each other
there's lots of people with very mild
sort of sore throat um and you're never
quite sure if it's something Brewing or
if it's just because you had a late
night so in those situations if you
don't have a fever and you're feeling
okay A little bit of a scratchy throat
you know those are times where you want
to stay away from people who are at more
at risk if you're working maybe work
remotely if you can or wear a mask if
you have to be around other people and
you know that's what I've been doing I
had my first scratchy throat a couple
weeks ago and it didn't turn out to be
anything but you know clean my hands
regularly stayed home for a day wore a
mask when I went into work the next day
so those are the things that we can all
do now that make a
difference Dirk Canadian press go ahead
Dirk um Dr Henry you said something
earlier in your spee or your news
conference here about a pneumonia kind
of situation in China right can you
elaborate a bit more on what might be
happening sure so um there was some
concern about two weeks ago that there
was a a surge of of particularly young
people going to hospital in a number of
areas of China particularly around
Beijing and in that Province um the who
asked for more information from from
China about what was happening and and
their investigation showed that it was a
variety of illnesses and the concern is
that this is the first year where they
haven't had major restrictions in place
in in across China because of covid and
that younger people are being exposed to
the usual things that they hadn't seen
for a few years we saw a very similar
thing last year where we had a an early
peak of influenza and RSV particularly
in children um early on in the season so
we're not seeing that as much this year
the other thing that was concerning was
um uh reports of type of pneumonia we
call it walking pneumonia or an atypical
pneumonia caused by a a a bacteria
called micoplasma micoplasma pneumoni
and we monitor that in uh in British
Columbia every year we have past um
sporadic cases and it is something that
can be a complication of a viral
infection and some people when they get
a viral infection the inflammation in
their lungs makes them more sucess
suceptible to getting a pneumonia
afterwards from a bacteria and this is
one of the ones that we've been
monitoring for we have a let's called
The Sentinel physician surveillance
Network across the country so it's um
four provinces across the country that's
run under the bccdc and they test for
micoplasma pneumonia we've seen I think
two across the country this year one
here in BC and we normally see sporadic
cases like this is prior to the pandemic
we would see them now and then and we're
seeing a very similar pattern now so
we're not seeing a concerning increase
in this type of pneumonia in BC and
we'll continue to watch for it and
things seem to be settling down in China
it's very likely that the pattern that
they saw was very similar to what we saw
last
year sure um coming in and work today
and on the weekend I'm just
wondering why why people are wearing why
some people wear a mask
Outdoors you know you know I think it's
personal preference some people feel
more comfortable they just wear it all
the time um the risk is much less when
you're Outdoors we know that um but for
some people it's convenient if they're
feeling unwell themselves it's a way of
of preventing um germs from leaving you
um as well we know that some people wear
it because it protects them from um
pollin and and uh pollution in the air
things like that so there are many
reasons why people do it um for me the
most important time to wear a mask is
when you're in crowded indoor settings
particularly around people you don't
know and if you're somebody more at risk
then wearing a mask is maybe an
appropriate thing the other place where
as you know we think it's incredibly
important for us to to wear masks
regularly is in healthcare settings
especially this time of year we know
there's people with respiratory
illnesses that are going into emergency
departments going into our hospitals
going into clinics and so that a time
when all of us should be wearing a mask
and that's part of our infection control
protocols in in the healthcare setting
right
now next we'll go to the phone uh Lisa
USA City News go
ahead Lisa are you
there we'll come back to you uh we'll go
now to go ahead y okay sorry I just I do
anyways multitasking um first about the
vaccines does your you know I had a
conversation with someone last week
who's very educated he's like oh I don't
think I need a shot I'm wondering Dr
Henry does your head just feel like it's
going to pop off sometime um with people
having this amazing thing available to
them and just not taking it yeah you
know there's a variety of reasons so
that people may or may not take it if
you've had um at least your three
vaccines so the primary series a booster
and a recent infection then yeah maybe
right now you don't need it but I still
encourage everybody um we know that the
protection I mean these are the things
that we're learning as we're going
through each year because we we can only
follow things as we go and we know that
protection from a at least the primary
series and and one booster gives you
strong protection of that cell mediated
immunity that memory immunity that
protects against more severe illness
hospitalizations but the protection
against getting infected in the first
place goes down after a few months and
that's why when we see a lot of the
virus circulating we want to boost up
that protection against infection and
that's what the booster dose does or
that's what this year's updated dose
does it gives your trains your immune
system to recognize the slightly
different strains that are circulating
right now so if I would encourage
everybody who's not had the updated
vaccine
so the xbb that gives that special
separate updated protection against what
we're seeing out there right now so it
is important it's something that will
boost up your immune system give them a
little bit of extra protection and
protection against getting infected in
the first
place Lisa do you have a
followup on a slightly different well on
a different subject entirely Vancouver
is considering the city of Vancouver is
considering um council's considering
increasing the number of licenses liquor
licenses extending some of the liquor um
hours the hours that liquor is
accessible and I'm wondering what kind
of health concerns you have to making
alcohol more accessible in in Metro
Vancouver and making it easier to get
licenses and and I guess just making it
more accessible well this is something
that we've um written letters on we've
done some reports on and my office is
working on another pH will report on
alcohol and we know that increasing
accessibility and lowering of cost also
uh leads to increase um problematic
alcohol use I would refer the city of
Vancouver to a very excellent report
done by Dr Patty Daly and her team at at
Vancouver Coastal Health around the
public health impacts of increasing
accessibility to alcohol I think it sums
it up nicely and I know she's presented
that to
Council next we'll go to Zara premi from
CBC ah yes thank you um my question is
quite similar to Lisa's but I'm still
going to ask it there are some people
out there who just don't want the
vaccine they're not against it they just
don't want it they've never gotten it
they don't feel they need it Dr Henry or
uh Minister Dix what is your message to
them what would you say directly to them
when they say I I just don't want it and
I don't need it you know most young
healthy people um we go through that
phase where we think we're
Invincible um we know from the data
that shows if you don't have uh if
you're unvaccinated across the board so
the vast majority of people in British
Columbia have had at least two doses of
vaccine vast majority have had at least
one booster dose after that and we know
from our seral prevalence studies that
many people have had uh an infection
often an inapparent infection so if
you're vaccinated you may not even
recognize that you've had it and that's
the good news so across the board when
we compare people who have vaccines plus
or minus infection with people who have
not had any vaccine they are at much
higher risk of having more severe
illness ending up in hospital or even
dying so that is um irrefutable that's
out there so I do encourage people to do
the best they can for themselves and
that means increasing your own
protection by getting this vaccine and
getting the updated one if you haven't
had one yet getting this updated one
will give you the the best protection
going forward and you just need the one
um and uh it also protects those around
you you may be fine and you may have a
mild infection you may not get that sick
with it but you can pass it on to
somebody else who may be at more risk
Zara do you have a
followup yes um actually it's Richard's
question but I'm hoping to see if we can
get the answer in French as far as what
is the province doing to increase
immunization
rates uh
[Music]
comp healthy
habits
p
[Music]
C perod
no
great uh next we'll go to Mindy Wen from
Fairchild Mindy go
ahead um hi Min de and uh Dr Henry um I
noticed that in BC the RSV vaccine is
not free for people and it is quite
expensive for for the public to to get
the vaccine so I'm wondering um uh with
the basic government consider to uh uh
to provide free RSV vaccine to to uh
people in higher risk thank
you very good question so the the RSV
vaccine there's one that's available um
that's been approved for use in Canada
and it's for seniors it's for people 60
years of age and older which doesn't
seem that old but um so and it's a
relatively new vaccine so whenever a new
vaccine comes on the market what we need
to do is say you know who's most at risk
from RSV what's the benefit that the
vaccine's going to have how many doses
do you need what's our population and
who's going to benefit most from it so
we haven't had the opportunity to do
that yet we also know that the
availability of the vaccine has been
relatively Limited in Canada this year
so we are looking at a couple of things
one we have a process in Canada where
our national advisory committee on
immunization looks at new vaccines and
answer some of those questions for us
they look at you know who's most at risk
what population should get it and then
we look uh we take that that information
and the recommendations from nassi and
we have a committee here in BC who looks
at the vaccines as well and says okay
what does that mean for BC so we're in
the process of doing that um the one
thing I can say is that our data show us
that it is RSV is primarily seen in
younger people and we know that there's
some vaccines coming on the horizon for
children and infants or for pregnant
people that will provide protection
ction to infants in their first few
months of life and so those are really
important vaccines that we're that we're
following as well and that should become
available but are not yet approved for
use anywhere in the world but should
become available in Canada in the coming
actually I shouldn't say that the one
for pregnant people is available in the
US but has not yet been approved for use
in Canada so those are coming down the
line as well and what we need to do is
balance you know how do we get who's
going to benefit most from the vaccines
that are available and how can we make
sure we have a program that provides the
most benefit to people right now there
are some availability of RSV vacines for
older people um and they are available
through pharmacies and for private
pay Mindy do you have a
followup uh no thank you great thank you
our last question La question goes to
wet Paul with Radio Canada go
ahead
[Music]
not message
is
if
[Music]
for
V
[Music]
a
per
[Music]
Sy
thank you very much or another question
anra question will that
followup for you also Minister
[Music]
dicks
period
[Music]
Grand
in me thank
you